[Music]
the internet never forgets news no they
don't I don't feel like they did oh yeah
actually yeah things passed pretty quick
Chris Brown did some crazy [ __ ] and he
was still my couple on the one before
like outrage for like two days
people are still bringing it up though
yeah because you did it again now yeah
cuz he did some other [ __ ] so they never
forget you didn't have like any legal
pet or something a parrot or something
just got busted for no I was like a rape
allegation and oh he says that yeah
Harris yo I didn't get that new update
then submitted by a dairy man
bring me that milk the opposite what
does that mean oh no that Joe means them
very mad cuz he's allergic
yeah I knew what you meant but it was
funny cuz what she said okay so I linked
it a children's YouTube entertainer
ashamed of hers past content is
discovered who are on know who was it oh
that sucks cuz content needs to be
judged with context in mind and
modern-day times versus otherwise people
are hunting down Twitter and like juice
is so racist in 2004 and in 2004 that
could have been completely cool I say it
in 2018-19 all the time you're just
saying you won't change
he's Popeye who is it
alright so you guys heard him blippi no
flippy never heard of this guy I haven't
that's a subway it's a subway thing
isn't it this is blippi blippi he is
very popular in children's youtube world
what is what did you make pretty much
like the New Era's mr. Rogers oh cool
like a clown version of mr. okay that's
weird yeah Rogers dream has big shoes to
fill sir I don't buy it because let's
close mr. Rogers is that he's not a
clown and he really sincerely likes kids
see that's a good comparison so the
minute you add
clown with kids you didn't know mr.
Rogers uh pee-wee Herman
yeah that would be a better better
compare okay so he's a pee-wee Herman
he's a perv
okay so we're clearly because something
just came out yeah what do I say that a
perv but this dude he's a he's a 30 year
old eccentric man what is that implying
something
I know right he's a flamboyant he's
young yeah he's esoteric I'm just
telling you the words BuzzFeed used I
don't know they they compare mr. Rogers
VA called him an eccentric but he
doesn't know [ __ ] we write this thing
anyway so this dude he has a YouTube
channel that has three and four five mil
and so now it's turned up that he
instead of blippi he had this other
stage name called steezy Grossman hmm
and back in 2013 he did a parody of the
Harlem shake do you guys remember yeah
no real one
no the Reverend yeah the fake one the
fake one I kind of funny insulting well
they call it the harmless all right the
fake one my power I know the real that's
all filthy Frank started that those of
you don't know what we're talking about
so it's where they play this song and
then there's one person that's kind of
like just moving a little bit and then
the beat drops and then like some crazy
[ __ ] happens yeah yeah so this dude did
one like a parody of it but it was
pretty gross so he even made a website
for it called Harlem shake poop calm
changes on YouTube now it's a separate
no they won't make it I mean his stage
name was something gross man so I'm
assuming all of this content was gross
yeah exactly what yeah because if it
wasn't I'm like what a waste of a name
so this is what he looks like without
the whole whippy get up okay and then
pee-wee Herman Lewis cz Grossman website
we had like a lot of turd boy
okay I don't know well yeah II don't
know their turn oh so I see that he's
been fine he's been finding himself as a
creator and then you finally found a
thing where he actually can make money
off doing yeah but before we get there
that I want to show you guys a drawing
of what the Busbee people drew of the
portrayal of this video that I couldn't
find because they don't want to put the
video out or maybe take it down yeah
they took it down I saw I saw they took
it down like his lawyers have like been
sending everyone like cease and desist
like it's like erasing it from the
internet yeah so I couldn't find you
could be up load it on other side yeah
I'm sure it's on Reddit someone got it
yeah so buzz we drew this so it's him
taking a [ __ ] on his friend as the
friends upside down like a spread [ __ ]
actually happen they said that it was
real poop so a jackass did it yes it was
very different so what's wrong with this
well cuz he that's kid [ __ ] now oh yeah
well kids videos watch this what's your
vocab yeah yeah in this one I gotta be
very specific the most friendly kid
thinks that's just a thing it's just
that the internet doesn't forget and
like his past has come up now he says
he's very embarrassed about it he's
really he regrets it but everyone grows
this is really weird cuz me and Joe had
a conversation about this the other time
where I just felt like traditional
artists they have a certain past that a
lot of social media people don't so I'm
a big fan of Miguel right the singer and
if you listen to his songs they're like
your pussy's mine I just want to like
[ __ ] your brains out and sniff coke like
he's some system crazy raw vulgar [ __ ]
but on the flip side he did a Disney
movie with Coco and he's saying like
half the Coco track yeah and so I'm just
like Disney and Pixar is as clean as it
gets and he did that I want to get
[ __ ] faded like a [ __ ] like
that kind of [ __ ] and I'm like how come
that's okay and no there's no outrage
there but someone like this where he's
just taking a [ __ ] on a buddy and now
he's making a kid's content like I don't
see the core of there's a generally a
generation thing of some nature were
like people on like of our age may find
[ __ ] on the Internet
right cuz we're messing around but maybe
like I guess you guys are parents too
but I just think of a parent like who
would be outraged by the Disney thing
because parents like you guys probably
wouldn't be maybe like he's not because
the stuff that my kid is consuming isn't
him going I wanna [ __ ] right right no no
I agree what I'm saying the person that
would be outraged is like a 60 year old
mom but the six year old moms not the
one hunting down the internet stuff to
know about steezy grossman or whatever
her to know about my girl yeah someone
found this and then put it on blast and
it gained traction I actually don't
think this is that bad either because
this happens a lot of traditional where
like they're doing like it'll be like a
[ __ ] Andy Dick Reilly him and his I
don't know show he does like crazy [ __ ]
and then he'll do like a random PSA like
hey kids don't eat lollipops and it's
like they it's like they're completely
caught that or any other super-clean
brand I don't know like KFC or all the
brands that are scared to work with us
they'll work with people don't work with
like ice cube check this out like we
have [ __ ] someone like Arnold
Schwarzenegger who's [ __ ] killing
people in movies and Ultra funk and
violent but then he becomes a state
governor you know like like that's
[ __ ] wild to me yeah so why it
depends on what it depends on what gains
traction so like there is no objective
here like there is no right or wrong
like where where you can clearly
identify it it depends on what group
starts to be outraged about something
and brings it out because there is a lot
of filth and there is a lot of people
with like a colorful background
we're like today they might be doing
something so pure and innocent or
whatever but yeah it all depends on what
you want to dig up and what you how you
want to crucify people yeah this could
have gone so much more worse in my head
like maybe not so much gross it's gross
that is gross I don't want more for me
leave for me as I leave it alone because
traditional media people don't have to
go through any of this yeah like
Jennifer Aniston can make any movie she
wants and then she could still be the
face of smart water yeah
first it's like social media is like
you're in bosses or what does that
yeah where she's kind of stripping yeah
yeah she's like a rapist or something
there right and it's just like but in in
fluent and like new media it's almost
like your content and your persona are
one of the scene yeah but in traditional
media that's the movie she made that's
what it's kind of saying like that like
if you played a role it's approved by
yeah yeah yeah yeah but recently I guess
a similar thing that happened was with
James Gunn where they dug up his old
tweets yeah but is this career over yeah
they kicked them off guardians of the
galaxy oh yeah they director right I'm
talking about people not what they've
done in their personal life just based
off content like Disney probably
wouldn't want to work with a Content or
personal - there's a scale to it - like
pooping on somebody's [ __ ] weird and
kind of gross but like sexual assault
like acts of racism acts of violence
those are different yeah sometimes no
they tell their I think tons get away
yeah like you're right cuz I mean are
Kelly still performing and even they it
took him a doctor documentaries years
ago right like the first are Kelly pedo
stuff was 10 years it still keeps yeah
it was a long time no no not when it
happened when he got caught he got
caught like 10 years going in it like
disappeared for 10 and that just came up
again he keeps getting away yeah easy
yeah his Browns another one all these
like a bunch of people get a good way
with should i internet and people just
forget but if it happened in like like
what pee-wee Herman got caught jacking
off in a movie theater adult movie
theater we were just talking about that
it was pretty much he was he was like oh
hmm yeah but I wonder if this will
affect the guy's views or anything I
feel like the kids are still gonna be so
addicted to those YouTube videos and
like they're not gonna know that he did
this you know like some of the parents
that were interviewed for this article
too they were like well it's not like I
would want my kids hug the dude but what
does that have to do with the content
that he's providing from you have the
new contents clean enough so is it just
BuzzFeed trying to like put this guy on
blast and then like well no just that
this is a story that's picked up so yeah
so then this all started from this
reddit thread for moms called does
anyone else want to [ __ ] flippy and in
one of them in that thread that's where
geo Antoinette started that Oh
if you know me you know I like athletic
dude he's a big guy you said you like
big guys he looks a little no he does
not he look so scrawny he's hella funny
no hey but he ain't my type we gas oven
someone commented on on that reddit
thread saying the man behind blippi
Steven Grossman changed his name now
understandably because he did - his name
was the guy behind the infamous Harlem
shake poop video where he has explosive
diarrhea all over his friend you should
check it out it's funny but then that
comment got deleted and then like that's
when his I McLaren team I can see why
he's trying to clean it up because it's
bad for brandy sure yeah you can't
associate the [ __ ] guy like with what
your kids watching you know if like if
Barney was in Barney's costume [ __ ]
like ten other dinosaurs like yeah it's
kind of hard this guy has three YouTube
channels so the main one has three point
six mil you can blippi toys where he
just plays with toy trucks or at a play
jim has over three mil and then a
Spanish dub flippy channel has 4.3 mm Oh
kid content is [ __ ] killing it on
YouTube oh all those channels have a
combined 7 billion views and in 10 years
those kids are gonna grow up and they're
gonna watch JK news let's wait 10 years
10 years baby
[Music]